There's been this press and this talk
that you participated, you're
in the bloodiest scene,
they're calling it the bloodiest scene
in the history of horror films.
And I think they have actual statistics
to back it up in this next film
is that true?
That's what I was told on set,
it wasn't real blood, obviously.
(laughter)
What if it was real blood,
and it was an incredible
waste of precious human blood.
Yeah, yeah, oh yeah.
Nine hospitals had no blood.
(Jessica laughing)
But they said it was worth it.
Yeah yeah.
That's why you shoot in Canada.
For my art.
(all laughing)
They're like,
well they needed blood
for their movie I guess.
(all laughing)
Can't help ya sorry.
Yeah sorry, I'm so sorry.
You're grandmas gonna go.
So wait so you were, it's
fake blood yes, but--
It's fake blood, it's 4500
gallons of fake blood.
(audience member cheers)
Right, woo!
(audience claps)
And that means that you are,
like you're whole, you're in it,
you're immersed in blood.
I was immersed in it,
I mean basically it's
kind of like a mixture
it's like KY jelly with red dye.
Oh (chuckles) well,
I've been there.
(all laugh)
Anyway.
(laughing)
Settle down, it's not that kind of show.
But, but you said,
you encouraged the director
go for it, you said--
I did.
Pour as much blood as
you got to, go for it.
Well, he said you know,
he was telling me about
the scene and he said,
you know its only gonna
go up to your chest,
and it's fine and I said,
well this is our opportunity to really
make something crazy,
let's do Carrie on steroids.
Right.
So I fully went in the blood,
which I regretted a lot afterwards.
Yeah.
I was pulling stuff out of
my eyeballs the next day.
Right, right.
That could have been your eyeball,
you don't know, what with
so much blood around.
Is it true that you do an impression
of Jessica covered in the blood?
Yeah.
And set up this impression for me.
Oh man--
Yeah.
Ah, you want an impression, buddy?
I'll get it for you.
Ah you want a Jessica
Chastain in blood, huh.
I'm gonna put a nickel in and there ya go.
All right, Jessica Chastain in blood.
(all laugh)
No what happened was when they would
pour the blood on Jessica,
it was incredibly cold,
and so when that happened
we knew that was our time,
that we were about to shoot any minute,
so we would hear this sound which was
(theatrical shivering sound)
(all laugh)
And then we would be like,
oh all right, here we go, all right.
She's like all right, let's
go let's go go go go go go go.